jobless claim rise sharply to highest
level since
2021. again this is a fox business story
uh let's see this here the number of
Americans filing for unemployment
benefits last week reached the highest
level since 2021 with initial claim
surging to buy 22 000 to 264. this
figure is well above the pre-pandemic
average of 218 claims and marks the
sharpest level of jobless claims since
October 2021 continuing claims which
represent Americans continuously
receiving unemployment benefits Rose
slightly to 1.81 million indicating a
potential cool enough in the
historically tight labor market
economists anticipate further increases
in unemployment as a result of rising
interest rates leading to potential
reductions in consumer and business
spending the FED projections suggest
that officials expect the unemployment
rate to rise above 4.6 by the end of
next year up from a current three and a
half percent this could result in over 1
million job losses by the end of this
year Tom what are your thoughts on this
story well this is exactly what the FED
wanted to cause is with um whether
they're the direct cause of it or it's
now we're going to a cycle because
because we had over hired in 20 and 21
but this is what the FED wants to see is
rising unemployment and jobless claims
is where it starts what's really
interesting is right now the employment
unemployment rate according to
government's 3.4 percent and so that's
5.7 almost five and three quarter
million people unemployed officially but
then we have this 1.9 million jobless
claims in there so when you look at this
and say that the last week the week's
claims is 264 000 that's like 25 percent
of the current jobless claimed so it
looks like this is inflating LinkedIn
came out yet another tech company just
laid off a little under a thousand
people and the list of tech layoffs we
had a couple sheets in here it was just
incredible Morgan Stanley 3000 3M 6000
to name a couple companies that were
outside Tech the headlines have been
Tech layoffs but it's all it's all
coming and people have been asking what
does this mean does this mean the
recession is here remember that's what
they're asking does this mean that he
keeps interest rates flat in June when
he gets along and we found an
interesting chart here really quick
Malik do you have the blue bars in the
league
just to give you a context to what Tom's
talking about when you said this is what
the FED wanted I believe you're
referencing The Showdown almost between
uh Jerome Powell and Senator Kennedy of
Louisiana when they had a little thing
going on his character was talking about
you're saying you yeah joblessness to go
up you want people to be upset and out
of work yeah once you can kind of get
past the almost like uh
he's talking about something called the
Phillips curve so back in the Phillips
curve they had this idea where there was
an inverse relationship between the
inflation rate and the unemployment rate
so if the unemployment was low uh then
inflation would be high and if the
unemployment as the unemployment rate
got higher then inflation should come
back down that was totally debunked in
the 1970s but for some reason that's
still part of their playbook now one
thing I'd also point out about jobs if
you go back a couple weeks or last uh
Friday I think it was the non-farm
payroll came out this blowout number
right but then they also revised the
prior two months down by like 150 000
jobs and I also saw a chart on Twitter
that was very interesting this chart was
how many consecutive months that the
actual number exceeded expectations and
it went back let's say 20 years right
and the most uh it got up to was about
four or five months consecutively where
they actual number exceeded expectations
now we're on 13. 13. I mean it literally
goes off the charts but what they do is
they've been revising down every single
month prior
you see so you when you think about it
it seems like what they're doing is
they're coming out with a blowout number
just to make the administration look
good and then the next month they're
just revising it because they know that
no one will pay attention to that and
they'll just sweep it under the rug so
if you look at the revisions as the
actual number then they jive a lot more
with this story that you're reporting on
than the actual headline non-farm
payroll so it's very suspicious to say
the least I love that you use the word
suspicious because I completely agree
with you and I also saw the um uh you
sounds like you're reading it the same
way I was about two months ago they had
gone in and revised the definition of
seeking work and it was actually 5.1
million were were had quote given up and
so they pulled them out of the
166 million total Workforce that they
estimate right yeah 62 participation
rate about 166 million people in the
workforce and they what they did they
pulled it out but if you put the two
together and you doubled it the
unemployment rate instead of being at
that point four would have still been
closer to seven and three quarters yeah
yeah and and the birth death model
correct I don't know if you saw that but
I don't know if you guys want me to
explain that but there's something
there's a an adjustment for the headline
non-farm payroll it's just birth death
so what they try to do it's not human
beings it's businesses so what they try
to do is Guess How many businesses were
started and how many businesses failed
within that time frame and then since
that's I don't know why they can't
report but for some reason those brand
new businesses can't reports they have
to guess as to how many jobs were
actually created based on how many llc's
came into existence and what's odd is
they just assume that every single LLC
that's created has x amount of employees
and you know as an entrepreneur that's
how they're guesstimating yeah that's
one of the reason that's one of the ways
they do that and so I I saw a lot of
people that I follow on Twitter that I'm
friends with that that are very very
smart yeah and they took out that
adjustment for the birth death model and
then if you do that then it was
basically zero and it was much much
lower which will most likely next month
get revised even lower than that
headline number so it's all this kind of
financial engineering so to speak that's
making the jobs numbers look as as good
as they can and keep in mind that's the
only thing that the fed and the central
planners and the Janet Yellen types have
to say hey look at how great the economy
is because every single other metric
that they have that even the FED said
like a year ago that this is how you
tell if we're in a recession I'm
referring to something called a
near-term forward spread I can I can
explain that if you'd like me to but
they used to say well this is what you
have to look at this is what you have to
look at until that inverted and then
like uh no don't look at that anymore
so this is all they've got left is the
unemployment rate and that's why they
might be kind of using these types of
financial services speaking of
suspicious but we did this on the
podcast two weeks ago how Biden created
10 million new jobs whatever the crazy
number was Rob you probably have the
link but it turned out it was just
people who basically were fired during
covet and then just got their jobs back
these aren't really yeah created jobs so
it sounds like but you could inflate a
lot of these numbers what do we expect
we I mean it follows the process you
first increase interest rates we've had
the fastest interest rate increases
since since anyone can remember
naturally that's going to bring down
inflation because spending is the first
thing that stops and only after spending
stops do people stop hiring people and
so the job numbers are coming down they
are manipulated
but I think more importantly I think
this is this is probably the more
important thing the fed's Mandate is
based on a a concept which was debunked
so the fed's Mandate is based on
inflation and unemployment that's that's
what the FED looks at if you've been
looking at what Jerome Powell has been
doing and saying no matter what happens
around it no matter what we think about
the banking collapse or whatever else
we're focused on inflation and we're
focused on unemployment and that's
really where the the Focus areas and I
think that the Mandate of the FED for
this kind of scenario is probably wrong
and I mean I like this in the in the FED
but I think the Mandate needs to be
redefined yeah and another thing that's
interesting we're on the topic of
unemployment is uh one of the
presentations from this weekend a good
friend of mine Jeff Snyder who's
probably the smartest guy I've ever met
uh he looks at those curves like the
near-term forward spread which is
basically the current three-month
treasury yield uh minus the feud the the
three-year treasury yield that the
market expects in 18 months based on a
variety of factors the price then yeah
or the yield so you look at the current
three-month yield compared to what the
market is predicting the three-month
yield will be in 18 months and then you
subtract that and right now there's like
a 200 basis point inversion
so what the market is saying is that
they're predicting an 18 months or
within that time frame the two-year
excuse me the three-month treasury yield
will be 200 basis points lower than it
is today so then he said you got to sit
back and ask yourself what does that
mean what what if if the if the the
three-month treasury yield goes down by
that much what would the economic
environment have to look like and where
would the FED have to have interest
rates as a result of that economic
environment some of the conclusions that
he came to is he thought that
unemployment would be at double digits
by the end of this year
double digits unemployment double digits
and he thought that based on that and
based on the yield curve the normal
yield curve and the near-term forward
spread and the the euro dollar Futures
curve and whatnot that the FED would
most likely be at zero percent by the
end of this year what you're saying is
pretty shocking you're saying it's a
three and a half percent now by the end
of the year no no the FED funds is right
now I think you're talking about
unemployment rate well yeah I am I'm
sorry I got unemployment as well so
unemployment goes from 3.5 percent to
double digits yeah by the end of this
year and the recession that's producing
that causes the FED to take rates fed
funds down from let's say five percent
all the way back down to zero percent
and that that and then think about what
type of economy think about the banking
crisis the thing about the Black Swan
event that we would have to have in
order for the FED to drop rates that
quickly and another thing that I would
add there's a a big psychological
component here right because you guys if
you study history you guys know that
history remembers Paul volcker very well
it does not remember Arthur Burnswell
right and he was the Fed chair that
preceded Paul volcker everyone thinks
that he didn't have the balls basically
to take interest rates high enough to
break the back of inflation and sure
enough Paul volcker comes in and he had
the huevos to get in there and do what
needed to be done even though it was
very unpopular so if you're Jerome
Powell who do you want to be remembered
as obviously Paul volcker so from a
psychological standpoint that puts him
in a place where if he's going to air on
one side or the other he's going to err
on the side of taking rates too high but
you see the market knows that and even
when you include that psychological
component they still are betting that
he's going to take rates almost down to
zero or around that uh area by the end
of this Union Snyder no the market the
market because if you look at how the
market is placing their bets the the the
bond market as an example that's what
they're saying is going to come to
fruition in the bond market is the Smart
money I mean if you look at just the
basic you curve with a two-year treasury
in the 10-year treasury you can take
that all the way back to 1950s and that
has almost a hundred percent accuracy
when that inverts you 99 of the time you
get a recession now what's interesting
is right now it's still inverted so the
two-year treasury yield is higher than
the 10-year treasury but the stuff
doesn't hit the fan when the curve is
inverted it hits the fan when the curve
is no longer inverted and what usually
happens is you have a bad inverter when
the yield curve steepens you have a bad
steepener and a good steepener the bad
steepener is when the two-year goes back
down below the 10-year and almost always
that's a result of the FED dropping
rates as a result of some sort of crisis
situation so those people that think
that the FED drops rates the stock
market is going to rip higher that
unfortunately they're on the wrong side
of history and they might get a a rude
awakening to say the least the bond
market is Right more often than the FED
narrative is right and if you're looking
at what the yield curve is almost always
right and if you look at what the FED
narrative is now the FED narrative is
now we're going to continue raising
until the data until the data says
otherwise but I think Paul Tudor Jones
was on CNBC today and he said I wish
they would say something what like what
they really wanted to say so I'm not a
big I'm not a big believer in the Black
Swan event which you which you spoke
about but I do think that there is
something else that threatens the job
market and could cause mass unemployment
and I think it's going to happen in the
next three to six months but I do think
it's gonna happen the next 12 to 18
months and that's AI so I think no one
is is forecasting for the dramatic
change that AI is going to have on
people's jobs because right now it's
just chatbots and we're seeing the
beginning of it but remember that AI
technologically does that yeah and I
think that that's gonna cause a lot of
people to lose their jobs and I don't
think we've recreated the jobs the new
jobs as quickly as we're going to lose
the old jobs and I think that's a big
thing that we're going to look out for
as I say I don't think it's three to six
months from but I do think that 12 to 18
months from here we've got a massive
jobs problem yeah and we're gonna have a
lot of unemployed people so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]